To continue, we are in fact interested in four different quantities.
One is a true positive.
A true negative.
A false positive.
And a false negative.
What this picture shows us here is actually what is called the confusion matrix.
This is called a confusion matrix because it makes it easy to tell whether
the classifier is confusing the positives with the negatives.
So here, the actual cases of negatives are on the top, or the x direction,
and the predicted cases by the classifiers are in this side here.
So true positive is an actual positive that has been predicted to be positive.
Similarly, a true negative is an actual negative that has
been predicted to be negative.
Now, you can also have false positives.
These are also known as type I errors.
In this case, an actual negative is classified or predicted to be positive.
Similarly, you can also have false negatives.
They're also known as type II errors.
In this case, an actual positive is predicted to be negative.
In the next video, we are going to define a few
performance metrics based on these concepts we just defined.